a very warm good evening good morning or
good afternoon in whichever part of the
world you are I would like to welcome
you all for today's Hands-On workshop on
biomedical data science in Python this
course will cover practical and
conceptual aspects of machine learning
and data science in application to high
throughput biomedical data using various
tools and python throughout the course
the students will get an understanding
of the opportunities and limitations of
data science and machine learning in the
context of pre-clinical and clinical
research the course is designed as a
combination of online resources
practical assignments and live workshops
that will be conducted online throughout
the course we will review several
project examples that demonstrate the
successes and limitations of
conventional machine learning methods
and deep learning as well using data
from public repositories
to begin with today's Hands-On workshop
I'll quickly first of all introduce
myself and also our company and then we
may proceed ahead with the workshop
so I'm sonalika Ray I'm the
bioinformatics project manager at Pine
biotech
and to introduce our company we are a
us-based bioinformatics company who is
working with multiple and academic
commercial collaborations to develop
easy to use analytical tools and our
mission is to make bioinformatics more
accessible and over the past several
years we have had the privilege of
working with a number of organizations
developing a training program for
research oriented students faculty and
democratizing bioinformatics making this
discipline accessible to thousands of
students and faculty around the world
omics logic research-based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between Pine biotech and
numerous academic institutions that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
the training follows a project-based
learning approach using research grade
tools to analyze data from Top peer
reviewed journals omics logic training
has been completed by students
researchers and faculty in six different
specialization tracks which includes
oncology infectious diseases Precision
medicine Neuroscience data science for
biomedical data and comprehensive
training on omix data analysis
the training has been completed by over
24 000 participants from 187 countries
and over 300 workshops and due to this
fast growth our team is now working with
local and Regional coordinators that are
helping refine the local program
Logistics and leverage our online
training resources adapting them to the
needs of students and researchers around
the world
I would like to introduce the founders
and the team members of the company Dr
Alfred Tauber comes from a medical
background with an expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
inflammation and one office major
projects is the establishment of Tober
bioinformatics Research Center which has
been at the core of what we do
is the director of Dober bioinformatics
Research Center and is an expert in
bioinformatics and biostatistics and our
platform is a result of hard work by
some of the people who are mentioned
here on the right
Dr Julia panav is an expert
bioinformedition Dr Mohit mazumdar is an
experienced bioinformatician with
multiple Publications in peer-reviewed
journals Dr raghavendran is an
accomplished computational biologist
with an experience in large scale
analysis of multi-omics data and data
science methods in Precision oncology
and protein DNA structural
bioinformatics
all right so now let's highlight some of
the current challenges and limitations
and how we at omics logic can help
resolve these with our training and
Research Services
so what are some of the challenges that
the fiend of bioinformatics is currently
facing
to begin this field is constantly
growing and developing new tech and
software to improve processing time and
power the data sets that are analyzed
are usually very large and take immense
amount of computing power and memory
that many personal computers do not have
also despite being publicly available
data is also usually complex to access
and coding knowledge is usually required
to do so similarly analysis pipelines
and programs require coding knowledge
that many biologists do not have in a
university setting students have the
opportunity to learn the background
information of Designing and
implementing a bioinformatics project
but do not receive practical hands-on
experience with the full workflow due to
the limitations that I just mentioned
similarly faculty faces challenges with
being able to cover a diverse range of
topics if they are specialized in a
certain area of bioinformatics or if
they are unfamiliar with bioinformatics
in general for example a professor whose
research focuses on oncogene expression
might not be much aware about
metagenomics of seawater
to overcome these challenges omic's
logic platform was developed this
platform aims to standardize organize
and systematize bioinformatics training
in order to make these analysis usable
for any biologist or a clinician
some problems for standardization
includes materials for these courses
that are usually developed in-house
taught sporadically and are rarely
updated
organization because the challenge is to
combine several different topics
together the flow and transitions are
needed to be developed and
systematization how can you know that
someone is stuck and needs help or allow
someone to run forward omics logic uses
standardized modules and interactive
sessions beginning with mastering
terminology and Concepts to implementing
these concepts with real data set in a
project-based approach
so what is our learning process
in order to create a clear path of skill
development omics Logic employs the
blooms taxonomy levels of learning this
approach starts with the basics where
students recalls facts and terminology
and are able to repeat and memorize the
material with this page the learning
builds to conceptual knowledge being
able to understand Concepts and apply
information to new situations the
student will then be able to analyze
data by drawing connections and evaluate
when to use certain methods this needs
them to the highest level of learning
the ability to design and create
original work
so how do omix logic resources help
Advance bioinformatics teaching
omics logic is a portal for practical
and theoretical learning of
bioinformatics which is composed of
courses designed to take you through the
theoretical knowledge
omics logic takes a combination of
training modules data analysis tools
curated project data sets and
interactive sessions with mentors to
keep a student a clear path of the
Bloom's taxonomy pyramid and no matter
what the user's initial experience with
bioinformatics is omix logic is a useful
tool for gaining a baseline knowledge of
the theory behind bioinformatics
analysis of large data sets and
introduction to basic coding languages
like R and python or beginning a data
analysis project altogether
users will be given directions to access
the T bioinfo platform for
bioinformatics processing and Analysis
of transcriptomics data the platform
includes demo pipelines as well as data
management and Analysis Cloud
infrastructure to run bioinformatics
pipelines different stages of analysis
are performed in different sections of
this multi-omics platform
this program comes with an access to the
omics logic courses which includes an
access to bioinformatics Precision
medicine multiomics coursework which
includes genomic transcriptomic
metagenomic epigenomic data analysis
data science that includes
bioinformatics using art and python
and example projects or case studies I
must say from different fields which you
could learn from and replicate for your
research work
so first of all let's begin by signing
up on the omics logic learn portal where
we'll be sharing the link of the portal
in the chat box and you can go ahead and
sign in let us know through the chat box
if you are logged in by typing in a yes
if you have already signed in then it's
good you can let us know that as well
once you have signed up you need to make
sure that you have a complete profile a
completed profile will include a profile
image full name with appropriate
capitalization link to your social media
handles which could include Facebook
LinkedIn Instagram Arc ID and Twitter
a brief pile about yourself that will
consist of educational background and
research interests the mentors can view
your progress under the activities Tab
and the courses you are currently
completing will appear under the courses
staff finally after the completion of
your course the certificates will appear
under the certificates tab
now I would like to give a quick demo
for those who have just joined us for
the very first time on how you can login
to the omics logic learn portal
smash has shared the link of the portal
already in the chat box
you just need to click on the login
button here and either you can create or
set up your credentials or use any one
of your social media accounts and sign
it
I'm awaiting for responses in the chat
if you have signed up or if you are
signing in please put a one or yes so
that we can proceed ahead today is a
Hands-On Workshop so we'll be expecting
you to follow the steps that the mentor
would be taking you through today we
will be running some code blocks from
the python coursework on the portal and
for that it's important for you to have
an access to the python coursework so
once you log into the portal
we have two courses on python
if you search in the search bar and type
python you'll find these two courses
that we have to go through so please
make sure that you are all set by
signing in on the portal so that you can
follow along the steps the mentor takes
you through
we'll take two minutes before I pass on
the session to Dr raghav so that he can
get us started with the workshop
just making sure that we all are set to
begin with today's Workshop
and for those who have already signed in
uh you can click on the mail address
which says welcome back and then your
email address when you click on it
you'll be redirected to your profile
section please make sure that you have
an updated profile so that we have a
good background about uh your
educational background and your research
interest and we can assist you
accordingly
I see just three responses
we'll wait for a minute more if you're
signing in
all right I think we are going to begin
with today's session
and now I would like to pass on the
stage to Dr ragher
to take the session ahead
Dr raghav over to you
thank you very much analika and uh
welcome all of you to today's handstand
session on uh Python's course let me
find ways to share my screen before that
yeah
so before that let's get a quick check
how many of you have some experience in
coding or specific to python Etc if
you're a complete beginner or a newbie
you can give a number like 0 to 2 and if
you have moderate experience like if you
know how to yeah thank you if uh if you
know how to plot one or two plots uh
like a box plot or like a bar plot like
a this like a scatter plot then you give
it five and if you know how to uh find
relevant codes from stack Overflow or
publicly available
discussion media and then modify those
codes to your needs and then presence of
decent plots then have seven and yeah
and under birth so let's see lot of
numbers less than two and thank you very
much there is a seven an expert there
that's good experienced person there and
then more some more entries okay so
that's this could be little bit
um
let's see basic for people who are uh
who have some experience but again I
usually tell this to many people uh
always mention this in these web
webinars that the focus is going to be
using omics data type
so
in spite of the fact that we have some
experience in Python and we know how
different uh tools and functions and
modules and everything has been used for
used in Python Sometimes some of them
might not be relevant for omics data
analysis some different types of
data wrangling and data analytics could
be useful for AMEX data analysis so um
yeah
congratulations Rohit yeah welcome here
to this session so let's see uh how you
interpret what we are going to discuss
today okay let's go over for example uh
what are we going to learn in the in the
program so this program is focused on
for example
um
uh biomedical data science so by meaning
or by uh Choice all the data sets that
you are going to deal with is going to
come from a biological data most mostly
bioinformatics data from high throughput
sequencing
index and structured data from omix data
analysis for roaming data analysis so
for those who are absolute beginners in
bioinformatics and who does not know for
example
how these high throughput sequencing
data is generated in what are the
different areas research fields and
translational application Fields where
these bioinformatics data analogy
analytics and bioinformatics
applications are actually concentrated
then we have an introduction session and
introduction resources lessons for you
so you will be required to go through
introduction to bioinformatics lesson
and bison molecule molecules lessons so
what is this going to tell you this is
going to this is not a coding oriented
lesson
permanent excuse me but this is going to
be an introductory lesson and an
overview lesson on bioinformatics in
general so if you come from a field that
is not related to biology or biomedical
science then you can go through this
these lessons and if you are from this
if you have some introduction to
bioinformatics already exposure to
bioinformatics already then still I
would give uh I would suggest you to
skim through this lesson maybe some of
the places where um
you think bioinformatics might not be
useful and applied we can cite you some
instances where it is it being extremely
useful some interesting options such as
for example Wastewater surveillance that
you already know for Search Group 2 and
for example space or mix well a major
part of research an interesting research
has been carried out by NASA and other
space agencies
expected to understand space effects on
issules and rather model organisms so
these are all some of the places where
we wouldn't have thought biological data
could be used and others and after that
you also have an introduction to getting
started with bioinformatics in Python so
what is this lesson going to deal with
so if you open this Associated resources
right it is going to take you to
what is Python and how to install Python
and generally take any structured or
table data and load it into Python's
environment that is what it is going to
deal with right and we want to we want
to help you learn the methods with which
you can understand the analysis analysis
and statistical methods and Analysis
that needs to be applied on
I'm mixed data right big data right
biological data
so the focus is going to be on the
methods and less on the technical
aspects of python for which um
you can refer Elsewhere for that so this
is generally going to start with
installing Python and some resources
where you can find more detailed uh
description of how to install python Etc
etcetera okay
so the one that we are going to deal
with today
is about data processing and exploratory
data analysis and why did I choose this
right I choose this I chose this
specific uh session and this specific
lessons to discuss with you because I
want to give you a taste of how data
exploration in omic's data analysis
um
now for example
um plays a key role in understanding
patterns and in setting up what needs to
be followed after these exploratory data
analysis right
but in any analysis right in any uh um
Advanced statistical or basic
statistical analysis you need to
understand what is what are the
relationship between the
um
features or what are the relationship
between the variables that you have so
that you can plan what are you going to
learn and what are the trends that you
are going to focus on and what are the
patterns that you want to understand Etc
and these becomes very important in the
context of biological data because one
day the lesson that you are going to
understand and learn is going to be
converted into a drug or is going to be
converted into a Diagnostics measure or
it is going to be converted into a app
with which is going to suggest you your
dietary plans so it's going to be that
important right so I analyze unlike
other internet of things and other
methods where you will get suggestions
and other
results based on your existing Behavior
so we are not going to use for that so
this biological data aromix data comes
with their own challenges and this all
the sessions here and this webinar this
Pro program also deals with some of
those challenges and how to understand
those limitations and also some
advantages also in another cases and how
to use it to our own Advantage so again
so that we can gain lot of information
and lot of hidden Trends and
relationships from the data that we are
focusing on so let's go to this specific
link I'm going to share this link right
you can access the lesson that we are
going to discuss through multiple
different modes right you can go to the
program page
and then in the program page under the
January 24th session right you can
choose to click on data wrangling and
visualization so this link will work
only if you log in and use the login
credentials that we have just created or
you have created earlier to log into the
learn portal that we have
so please log in and open this specific
program page and click on this
visualization if you click you are going
to look at a page like this
and the more General way of
understanding or more General way of
reaching this lesson is through
um
python course introduction to data
science python course 2 introduction to
data science in Python uh this is kind
of an advanced course where we have a
python course one which talks about
absolute basic level so if you are a
newbie so I would want you to focus on
that and
um for today's purposes we can discuss
or we can go through the lesson number
two of this particular course so if you
want to go through the course and what
other uh options or what other analytics
that we have and that we are going to
focus during the course of this program
is also outlined here some of them are
star so that required for that requires
for example subscription and some of
them are left open so that you can
explore that something like this and
something like this for 24 hours so that
you can make a decision about your
subscription to the program
okay if I click on this link so I'm
going going to get a
page like this so what does it tell you
so I before going into the code section
I want to briefly show you how for
example
um and the lessons coding lessons are
organized in omics logic learn portal so
they are always organized with the aim
or specific aim or understanding the
problem or introduction to
um understanding the problem as a first
portion right so the aim of this
specific lesson is to get an experience
in data wrangling with python and some
useful data visualization in Python with
which we can understand the trends
patterns and relationships in the omics
data so that is what we are focused on
so we have a related video it's very
very useful to go through that video and
this video is is a is a small portion of
uh of sessions that you will be going
through in the in a program like this
and then coming down we have different
sections and different areas which is
described in the video and which is
going to be focused for this lesson
right we are going to focus on how to
plot using box plot or for example bar
plot and scatter plot thank you
so that we can understand the trends
right so each one of these plots right
we can create as many plots as possible
but each one of this plot is going to
give us some information about the data
about the pattern that is not going to
be available in the other plot so the
choice of the plot becomes important in
what are you trying to understand right
and the choice of representation is also
going to be important for example when
you have a multi-class scatter plot like
this you cannot do with just using two
or three different colors so you should
know how to access and handle different
types of colors and how to for example
stack plots on top of each other like
this so that you understand and compare
the trends of uh whatever measurement
that we have here to understand which
sample has different kinds of trend and
which sample has this specific kinds of
trends that more focus on what data it
is and how that is going to help us
understand the sample distribution is
going to be in the program so for
beginners this is transcriptomics data
and this describes the gene expression
difference between for example one type
of sample compared to the other type of
sample okay
let's go over and then come down so this
gives you a taste of how code blocks and
Associated discussions and explanations
around the code block is organized in
this particular lesson codes are always
organized as these code blocks which you
can copy
and then
paste it in Python's environment to
understand how they work and what what
they run and most of the data that we
are going to help you load and share is
going to be
shared with online based resources like
for example this on our server sometimes
you will find Dropbox links sometimes
you'll find GitHub link so you don't
have it is not a data Centric you don't
have to download this in your machine
and then install some of the modules in
the machine and go about it so that is
that
then for example after this what are we
going to do to this data so we are going
to perform for example this log
transformation and how do we perform
this clock transformation becomes a
focus of this particular code block this
is the organization of uh these lessons
right so before jumping into this learn
the code section once you have gone
through this learn the code section
always which always follows the
introduction or what is the problem or
understanding the problem section where
you start appreciating the nuts and
bolts of the necessary codes that we
need to understand to make this aim of
achieving or aim of getting a plot done
right we start from as basic as
importing necessary modules right and
then go to what are the some some useful
functions that you can use to verify
whether the
data is loaded properly or not and then
for example one more library that we
might we may need or we will definitely
need to visualize and then comes the
code blocks right like this
and then for example we give you
um
properly commented areas sometimes they
are here here for example yeah properly
commented sections of a big blocks of
course which will help you in
pre-processing which will help you in
extracting relevant information from the
whole table that you are going to focus
on to load into Python's environment so
the I what I want to describe and what I
want to demonstrate you is for example
after learning the necessary code pieces
right that that forms the center for
understanding how to create a plot like
this right and which is going to tell us
um
what are the different gene expression
patterns of four different sample types
right
and you can then come down to practice
yourself section where you can practice
what you have learned in the above
section in here itself you don't have to
go elsewhere to uh to test your
knowledge or to test your understanding
of how to uh have a code playground
where you can write your own codes or
for example complete the challenges that
we have underlined and we have detailed
for you to do right so what do we have
here so for example we have the data
right and due to the way in which python
is python is going to be installed and
python is going to be loaded in your
browser and we have to download this
particular input file let's do that so
how to do that you know how to download
this file so you always saved in cash
and place it in any folder let it load
okay
let's put it here save it
they already have it that's okay so
replace it so first download this file
available say I said okay we deleted
yeah so what is this focus is we have
for your practice once you have gone
through the code section we have deleted
some of the syntax and some of them are
left incomplete so that you can
understand by completing them the
um how to I mean how different areas of
this code will come together to help you
achieve the necessary
um goal right okay this this doesn't
need any file for example let's see if
there is any anything problem in this
particular
code block I'm just loading the packages
here let's see uh it will take little
bit of time to load for it because
python actually works as being loaded in
your computer's environment and your
computer is always influenced by whether
you are sharing the screen whether you
are a part of any other whether you're
running any other analysis or how much
memory you have exactly okay
once you have once you have completed
you say that you have you are successful
in running the code and then you have
achieved the uh
achieved completing this particular task
so this is very simple of loading the
necessary data necessarily the necessary
packages but this is going to be a
little bit challenging where we have
um
left little uh some of the portions
incomplete so after going through
today's session and after going through
this code I want all of you to try this
and and see if you can complete some of
the easy or some of the straightforward
challenges and some of that
challenging challenges or more hard
challenges which are going to be focused
as you go along in this test your
knowledge area right and finally you
have the complete code where you can for
example change some portions of the code
and use this as a proper code playground
to understand we'll come back to this
hopefully when we have some time let's
see if this is now if this needs any
difficulty okay let's run this okay so
there is an error because there is there
are some uh incomplete areas in this
code for example what is the computer is
let's quickly take a look at
this is fine this is fine and this is
fine for example uh Proto show is fine
oh this is okay this is only log okay
print log scale transform data
okay there is some error in this one
hmm
okay sometimes even though some of the
codes are correct this might give you
some hiccups because of as I mentioned
the python is actually loaded in your
computer and that is prone to some
issues so for this purpose today we will
focus on how to take some of these codes
and explore how to run in Google collab
environment so quickly give me a one or
yes if you know how to access and how to
understand different I mean understand
running a python code in Google's collab
environment so if not then let's take a
quick look on that so let me give you a
link for opening a Google call app
this is a yeah okay thank you very much
I think both of you are slightly
experienced yeah uh from your responses
I learned that so this is a Google
collaboratory notebook right so what is
this used for this is an online version
of Jupiter notebook which you can load
it in your computer jupyter notebooks or
notebooks that will run Python's codes
in your computer in your own browser but
this is exactly the online version of
that so uh let's see
um
whether this one will work
okay it's not working
okay
open your notebook
okay this is what we want I think
okay you can you can probably take a new
notebook here uh
check if this one works for you or if
not you might have to open only
collab.research.google.com and then open
a new notebook from this okay
type like this if you do this collab dot
uh
if you do this it's going to ask you
like this and open up a new notebook
from here yes open a new book from here
if you get this thing I think that's the
best way to open a python collab
notebook so open open this notebook
everybody let's
go over some of the codes that we want
to discuss today
just quickly give me a yes if you have
if you are seeing or okay I
suppose it
in your notebook if you are looking at a
screen like this let it load
an empty screen with one block
so some of the advantages of using
something like this so quickly give me a
yes if you see us if you look if you're
looking at a screen like this some of
the advantages of working in Google
collab like environment is for example
you can get a link of this collab and
share it with your peers share it with
the mentors and see and ask for feedback
on your assignments or on your codes
that you have tried right my first
Google collab
okay so give it a name so give me yes
quick quick in the chat where you're
able to load this up and look at this
particular screen
yep great some more responses
so we know some some people who have
experience in loading this up and they
are going to be a little bit ahead of
you I want some responses from people
who are starting
can you open this up quickly others
let's get some thank you usma and others
okay so once you see such a screen you
have to connect right you have to
connect to let Google
allocate some resources so that you can
run some python codes so it is
initializing let it do so once you
connect you will see a screen like this
then you can run your blog so what are
we going to run so let's go to our
python lesson
and in the learn the code section so we
don't want to go there we go all the way
down to learn code for data manipulation
and visualization right so here we are
going to use omics data to visualize
what uh how to for example uh make a
plot like this and what does this mean
right and what does this mean right so
why does this look like this in first
case right so these things we will
definitely discuss today quickly so for
that as I mentioned we have to import
some of the modules so
in Python nothing works without
importing models so take this copy this
particular section
I hope you know where to uh
take this from if not then I'm going to
paste it here copy the ones that I
pasted to you and then inside this this
is a code cell okay you have a code
block and you have a text block this is
a code block how can it tell this is a
code block a code block always has a run
this block or run this cell option on
the left right we cannot run anything
that does not have any input so I'm
going to paste this
paste it and then I run it
so this is simply importing the module
this is not going to give me any output
so when if you are here then then that's
good so you have imported pandas and if
you have imported numpy uh in your uh
Python's environment so quickly run and
give me a yes that you are here we are
going to copy the next block of code and
understand what that code actually gives
you thank you so how to open another
cell right you can obviously press enter
enter enter enter and keep running
multiple times but we don't want to do
that we don't want to execute the same
piece of code that we have done
executing so we want to open up another
cell next cell can be opened up by
hovering here so that you can get this
code option or keeping this particular
cell active and then
inserting a code cell below I have
inserted a code cell below so what do I
want to take so I want to take okay
let's load a transcriptomics data and
see what's inside the data so that's
what it is this block is so copy this
so this block will actually help you
load a transcriptomics data
so what are the what are what what do we
have here it's pretty straightforward so
we are just using the pandas library and
read underscore table function and
inside the read underscore table
function we are going to give this one
necessary input that it always needs
right the location where the file where
we have the file so you remember this is
a cell lines expression that we have
downloaded so we have not uh gone
through the downloads at all so let's
let's see if I can actually download if
I can actually show you uh
what does that look like so this is what
a typical expression table will look
like so
so you will learn about what these what
these are and how to how to understand
different portions of this table in the
program but for starters I'm going to
show you that for example any expression
data or transcriptomics data that is
shared over the internet from
Publications from repositories processed
data from repository is going to
organize like this we have genes along
the rows and we have samples along the
columns and their gene expression
measurement or quantification is going
to be populated in each and every set so
this is the information or an
information like this is what we are
going to load in Python's environment so
let's go back again here and this is the
location where we have the input file
that you can load and once you have
loaded this and uh
um
loaded this file and saved it into an
object called gene expression that
object is a data frame then we can look
or peek into the first few lines of the
data frame using this head what is not
opening you're not you're not you should
not open it you just copy it and paste
it in the next cell and run it
like this
the file opening is actually I gave you
as an example so you don't have to worry
about that we are look at this when you
uh
execute this code we can peek into the
table in Python's in the non-met itself
so what is the issue uzma
so you don't open you don't download and
open it that's enough that's I just
downloaded that particular file and
showed you how an expression table is
going to look like so you copy this and
paste it in the cell and then take a
look at the first that's okay take a
look at the first few lines just like
how we have uh observed in the other
expression table this is also another
expression table where the gene IDs are
The Ensemble IDs and they are populated
as rows and the samples sample IDs are
samples are populated as column and
their expression values are in the
format of fpkm you can actually find
what fpkm in the relevance lectures when
we are discussing this particular
session okay let's move forward so we
have loaded the file into Python's
environment so what do we learn from
that right and what do we have to do for
example
we can take use this option right
to describe some statistical properties
of our data frame that we have just
loaded so you copy this okay not this
you copy this and open up another cell
and paste it okay sorry
I think my existing but
Properties or you can type
right
okay paste it and run
so what do you see if you run
what are these can somebody tell me so
not only running the codes blindly uh
running the course blindly will not help
us we have to understand what these
outputs mean in the context of omics
data right
and that is also going to be discussed
in the session I'll give you a sneak
peek for example these are the
statistical uh description or parameters
of each and every sample right for
example take the first sample there are
something like 20 000 accounts in the
first sample and we have a mean value of
42 and standard deviation etcetera we
have a minimum of 0 and a maximum of
fifteen thousand something and we have a
median of 4.3 what does it tell right
this was just bunch of numbers but what
does it tell it tells some important
story so it tells that my data is
usually uh imbalanced right and skewed
let's not say imbalance it's not in
Balance it's queued so I have a minimum
value of 0 and a maximum value in the in
the range of thousands but my mean and
medians are completely out of sync right
in any
um normal distribution or a distribution
that follows gaussian distribution your
mean and median should be very close to
each other my mean and median are
extremely different so that tells that
my data is heavily skewed right so
that is an important information that
you can learn from this omics data are
sometimes heavily skewed unless and
until they are normalized into some form
of normalization you are going to look
at heavily skewed data sometimes we use
the data as it is required by some of
the analysis but sometimes we have to
normalize it so that we can pass it on
to the relevant analysis methods so
let's go forward so what are we going to
do so to understand for example not just
looking at the data in terms of number
we can plot so let's take this
and then open up another core block
and plot the file plot the data so what
do we see here
we are just plotting it as a box plot
right so how do you plot as a box plot
you just type the name of the data frame
and then plot dot box and if you just
leave it as it is then you are going to
get some values so I want you to try
that option Also let's try that option
and compare let's open a code before
this code like this so I am going to
just write gene expression Dot Plot dot
box so if I run this
so what do I get
right so I get a normal plot a box plot
with some parameters or with some uh
display parameter settings uh did by
default right if you look at our sample
name we see that our sample names are
long right so the sample names are
overlapped and it is hindering from us
to understand which distribution belongs
to which sample so that's why we are
rotating the x axis labels ectic labels
by 90 degree so that we can read them
and then we we give a title for this box
plot right the title is also not bad so
you can keep beautifying by giving a
color and etc etc which will be
discussed in other sections and other
areas of this particular lesson okay
I have been going Yaya about this box
plot for last two minutes and there is
no box
can somebody tell me why is that the
case
we know what a typical box plot will
look like
okay a typical box plot will look like
this
if I can find one
okay this is okay this is about okay a
typical box plot will looks like look
like this yes thank you I think typical
box plot will look like this we have
this box representing that 15 percentile
or 2050 to 75th the percentile of the
data or majority of the data
distribution is here and we have median
here and we have 95th percentile here
and we have fifth percentile here and we
have some of the other data that lie
Beyond this distribution of fifth to
95th the percentile of your data that
are
displayed as markers in box plots
language these are called outliers but
in omics data analysis these will become
significant uh Gene Expressions uh gene
expression signal that we will base our
analysis also in box plots language they
are called outliers and they are
described or they are actually depicted
as markers but uh due to the data that
we are dealing with which is heavily
skewed they are not uh outliers as such
they are outliers technically but those
outliers are the necessary signals that
we need to understand the pattern that
is present in our data okay
this is what we have so the same plot we
have used some interactive plotly option
to describe it in this way so the boxes
are actually concentrated here right
just as um
I cannot pronounce your name sorry
Azad right can I call you Azad right
um
yeah thank you as that mentioned rightly
mentioned they are concentrated here
because of this skewness of the data and
some of the hints to the skewness of the
data can be observed here also as we
discussed for majority of the data we
have the maximum values in the order of
tens of thousands that's what we see
here and we have mean and median values
concentrated in the order of tens or
fives or something like that which is
what okay so this happens because of the
skewness of the data and one of the way
in which you can address this is by
transforming or
um by transforming your data into a
logarithmic scale right
and how do we do that for example
uh we take
the same code right
just add one more option of for example
take next code
give the message here
okay copy it and paste it here so what
is the difference between this code and
the previous code
we just say whether or not do we want to
scale up the y-axis in a logarithmic
scale
that's what we tell here log y right
scale the y axis that's where the Y is
coming from and uh to a logarithmic
scale and we are going to use the option
as or we are going to give the option as
true
when you do that or when you perform
this analysis we get this distribution
so obviously this is not an interactive
but we get we understand the sample for
example we understand that all of the
samples have very uniform median values
they have a very uniform expression uh
General expression average but their
distributions are different for example
the majority of the distribution here
nset here this point but this is longer
and this is even longer right and the
outliers are the significant signals
that we will be focusing on during the
statistical analysis part is also
different here right so that's what we
can understand from here also right you
see some of them go as high as 16 000
and some of them stop but for example at
eight thousand so these things are very
very important when you are comparing
the expression patterns of let's say
this sample with respect to this sample
so those comparison can arise from such
exploratory data analysis that's why we
have to explore our data okay okay
if you want to work with some for
example interactiveness of this plot you
can you are very you are most welcome to
try it okay so what do we do next right
so we can for example go along and uh
use these options to for example stack
one gene on top of another Gene so that
we can understand that particular Gene's
expression pattern across the sample so
this G is expressed approximately
similar pattern along the different
across the different samples except for
one or two which can be which in which
this they can be expressed at a higher
okay but this Gene is completely or we
can even say one step higher this Gene
exhibits characteristics that are
statistically significantly different
from this particular G so we can
understand yeah we can do similar
analysis and print out these options
like this and
okay you can also perform scatter plot
so I'm I want all of you to go through
this whole lesson right this is this is
a very useful lesson uh where you can
understand different ways in which you
can simply plot a table of numerical
values to understand their pattern
forget about what they implicate the
implication part and relating that to
the biological uh phenotypical
characteristics of the data and
biological conditions under which the
sample is measured will be discussed in
detail during this program during the
session that's what you will learn take
these standard methods of visualizing
any numerical metrics or a data frame or
a table right and understand their
important outputs in the context of
biological or bioinformatics data right
like what we discussed here
in any bio in any box plots language
these are the outliers and they might be
subjected to two uh ignoring or
completely discarding them but for us as
I mentioned these will form the basis of
significant signal based on which we
will understand the groupings of samples
and Sample difference okay for some of
you mentioned that you are not uh as
experienced in Python and programming
generally so I am going to show you for
example how to
if you are if you are if you fall into
that criteria so instead of accessing
python course 2 you can go to python
course one
this python course one has a toned down
version of same visualization and data
wrangling part where we are going to
focus only on for example some of the
things that we discussed today right so
you can sonalika can you please check
the embedding of this particular plot
which is not available so this is a very
short uh introduction to data
visualization using python
so that you can obviously try so if you
are a beginner in Python I would want
you to go through this lesson person
this is also uh left free for you to
explore
24 hours and after that
once you feel comfortable after that you
can go to the advanced visualization
course
and data dangling and advanced
visualization lesson as described and as
referred in the uh program resource okay
I with that I can actually ask if you
have any questions regarding uh how we
can access the associated resources and
what we actually experience today right
and I also spoke about for example
sharing your collab and this is how you
do it for example this is a kind of
example data wrangling session that you
will actually get get to work with in
each and every session I would walk you
through each and every code just like
what I did here right to various
different methods and and creating
various different plots and discussing
everything right why do we need to do
that right this is what we discussed
today and different methods of creating
that plots right and what are the
different ways in which for example we
can make groups of this right we can
create like this also this is what a
sneak preview or sneak view of what you
are going to get for the second session
okay and once I am done discussing this
with you in the live session then we are
going to share this collab with you
right and we will copy this link and
share it with you so once you get this
link and you can open it and make a copy
like this save a copy and write and that
copy you can use and you can edit the
codes run the codes so that it is
getting saved and practice what all we
have discussed during the sessions
lecture so this is what we will share
and if you have some practice collab and
if you want to share it with me share it
with our team to understand what you
have gone through and if you have some
difficulty in for example uh in
executing some of the commands right for
example let's say I have a I have an
error in this particular one and I don't
know what is that error then I can for
example block this and comment
right
error please help me fix it
and then once you did do this you can go
to share
and you can go to share and change the
appropriate permissions like
any one yeah restricted anyone with the
link
and anyone with the link can actually
comment
or sometimes edit also so we need editor
permission so that we can edit your
codes right and once you have done that
copy the link
right and then it and then send that
link to support.bio
right supported find or bio so that will
reach us and it will reach our team
right not only myself or not only the
mentor it will reach our our team our
technical team it will reach the CEO it
will reach everybody so that everybody
can have access to your code and some of
us will respond within uh within a span
of let's say 8 to 12 hours right so that
way you can stay updated with the
sessions that we are discussing and
practice on your own share your
assignments with us Sometimes some of
these collabs that we are discussing
will come with some test yourself
challenges or practices or assignments
that you will need to go through in
order to complete your understanding for
that particular session
I think I have gone little bit overboard
I will hand this session back to
sonalika I think uh and if you have any
further questions please type it in the
chat box I'll be happy to tend to that
okay
thank you and hand it over to you
sonalika are you there
uh yes thank you so much
yes for the Hands-On uh session so I'll
quickly uh guide everyone whosoever is
in the session with the registration
process and the resources
so hello everyone uh my name is sparsh
and I am the marketing manager here at
Pine biotech and I'll quickly guide you
all through the resources and the steps
to register to uh for the program
so uh this is the program page as you
can see on my screen
I'll just quickly uh copy paste the link
and share here in the chat box
uh thank you shubham for sharing
now uh the program is going to commence
from 28th January that is on Friday this
week and those who haven't enrolled in
the program but has only registered uh
please the date is fast approaching
enroll yourself and we are right now
giving uh up to 50 scholarship to all
the candidates
so if anyone is having any query
regarding the scholarship uh shubham are
representative uh would be sharing the
details and you can ping us at that
particular contact or the mail address
and they will accordingly guide you
so when I scroll uh down there is a
program overview and in this program
overview we are giving you a brief that
how what all uh things we'll be covering
in this program how different modules
are designed so in this particular
coursework we will be covering practical
as well as some conceptual aspects of
machine learning and in aspects to the
biomedical data using some different
tools of python
Etc
so now you will scroll down you will
find on your left hand side an
interactive session a calendar where
there are some dates highlighted sorry
where there are some dates highlighted
so uh the first session is on 20th as
you can see then the second session is
on 24th and the third is on 27th 31st
and so on so and on the right hand side
you can see that uh the first session is
on introduction to the program and the
topics which we'll be covering in this
session would be introduction to the
program the objectives the syllabus the
training resources coursework Google
collab notebooks uh recordings overview
of big biomedical data omics Etc and
session there will be some Associated
resources or links which we will be
sharing with only the participants of
the program who will enroll themselves
so as you scroll down you can see uh
then the second session would be on data
processing and exploratory analysis the
third would be on machine learning
methods unsupervised and supervised
types of the analysis and so on
so in the end we will be concluding this
program on how you can design your own
project once you have gained all the
theoretical conceptual as well as
practical knowledge of the biomedical
data science in Python so how you can
design your own project using this and
finally how you can submit that
particular project in a good peer
reviewed journal and get it published so
moving further
you can see here that there are uh three
different tenures in which you can
enroll for and uh one is 45 days another
is 60 days and then is 90 days
first of all I'll tell you the common
resources which will have access to when
you enroll in this but in the program so
the common resources as you can see here
is online tutorials project examples
Cloud pipelines access coding sessions
session recordings if you by any reason
um didn't join the live session so we'll
be sharing the session recordings as
well with the participants online Mentor
support and Online technical support via
WhatsApp groups or maybe Skype group or
maybe Telegram
then this certificate after completion
of the program so these are the common
resources which you'll have access to
now what's the difference between the
three uh tenures in the 45 days tenure
you'll have access to the training
material training part only where you
will get full flesh training on uh data
science on python how to use it Etc and
how to finally draft out your own
research project out of it in the 60
days 10 year you will be having two
different opportunities one is the
one-on-one Mentor support and second is
uh the extra time to work on your
research proposal and present it to
Mentor for evaluation purpose so by
one-on-one Mentor support I mean that
for example buy any XYZ reason you are
not able to join the live session and uh
you you were going through with your
trading material your module your
curriculum Etc and you get stuck
somewhere so you can come in communicate
with any of our manager maybe Community
manager or project manager or technical
manager and fixer kind of for 20 to 30
minutes
exploratory call with the mentor and get
your queries clarified so this uh
opportunity is there in 60 days and the
second is once your 45 days of training
is over you can draft a research
proposal presented to Mentor for
evaluation purpose Mentor will validate
will evaluate your research proposal and
will guide you accordingly if there are
any changes or Amendment need to be done
if not uh then you can proceed further
with the experiment with the research
project development now in the 90 days
tenure
uh you again have two different
opportunities one is obviously the
one-on-one mental support the second is
the extra time to work on your research
project so the first 45 days will be
devoted to your training part and the
second 45 days will be devoted to your
project uh work that is your research
project that is how you can develop your
experimental design and then finally
implement it so the outcome of 60 and 90
days is a poster presentation in a
research Symposium or any International
Conference or if you want to get your
paper published also then definitely you
can get it published in a good peer
reviewed journal in 90 days 10 years so
as now moving on with the pricing part
the pricing which you are right now uh
seeing on my screen is in naira but
those participants who are right now in
Nigeria or in African Community so the
for 45 days it's naira 49 uh 50 000 then
for 60 it's naira one lakh and then for
90 days it's naira one lakh 50 000. and
simultaneously
if you are from any other location for
example if you are from USA or you are
from India or from Europe you can
accordingly change the currency
according to your location and see what
is the fee for the program
for now I'll just show you in uh naira
in USD and then in INR for us people it
it's a 150 for 45 300 for 60 days and
then for 450 for 90 days and when you
scroll up
it's INR
okay
so
[Music]
um
just a moment
foreign
login so no problem so for INR uh the
pricing for 45 days is 7500 rupees then
for 60 days it's um
then for 60 days it's a 9 000 uh sorry
10 000 and then for 90 days it's 15 000
and right now we are providing with 50
percent like up to 50 scholarship so
those who are interested please uh share
your email address in the chat box and
we will definitely get back to you and
will revert with the solution and the
scholarship which we can eventually
provide to our participants who are
interested and willing to join the
program so this was all about the
pricing part I'll just quickly show you
the pricing in INR also
so for 45 days it's 7 500 for 60 10 000
and for 90 15 000. so this was all about
the resources the registration part the
fees in three different locations you
can change your location and pricing
accordingly
now if you click on this uh buy now
button for example I want to go for 90
days I'll simply click on buy now
and I'll be redirected to the payment
checkout
I'll simply write here uh the coupon
code whichever coupon code really
providing you according to the
scholarship
filling out the user details clicking on
this check box and then moving further
with either strike payment through
credit card or via PayPal so this is how
you can proceed further with the payment
uh also and we are having other
alternative options also for the payment
process it's UPI it's bank transfer
Etc
so if anyone is having any query
regarding the registration process or
scholarship please feel free to Ping in
the chat box and yes we will be sharing
the recording also with everyone by
tomorrow
thank you
um
so uh yeah so every okay
perfect so those who have shared their
email address we will be getting in
touch with you by uh
tomorrow morning uh your according to
your time zones and we'll guide you
accordingly how much a scholarship we
can provide with you
uh is there any mental guided course for
transcriptomic analysis yes there is
definitely a course on transcriptomic
data analysis and you can mail me
regarding your requirements at
marketing.com and I can provide you uh
with
an appropriate link
yes thank you what are the general
criteria for obtaining these uh
scholarships so uh
once we get an email from your end that
yes you want scholarship so we will be
sharing a scholarship form with you you
need to fill out that form and we will
discuss with our internal team about the
scholarship and then according to maybe
if if anyone is from a low income
country or depending upon the reason
we'll decide some scholarship and also
in some cases we talk with the pis or
the faculty or the reference they have
given in the scholarship so yes this is
a criteria which we follow
for deciding the scholarship I hope I
answer your question Azad
you're welcome
if anyone is having any further question
uh please feel free to bring
uh thanks shubham for sharing the steps
to register so shubham has already
shared the steps to register for the
program and you can like paste this
these steps somewhere and follow
according to these steps follow the
registration and enrollment part
so the prices I just showed you for the
program these are without scholarship
azadis are not with scholarship
so yeah
uh Ahmed it depends uh we do provide 50
scholarship and uh by like
I guess 10th or 15th of January uh we
were providing the 50 scholarship only
to everyone not only a particular
student a participant or joining to
everyone but it depends so you can
simply mail me and we can tell you the
coupon code uh by filling out your form
it will review your Form application and
then uh we'll get back to you with the
coupon code
you're welcome
are there any more uh questions
uh if not then I guess we are good to go
and I hope I see maximum of you in our
very first session that is on 20th
January
and uh brainstorm more about python
so perfect I guess there are no more
questions
so uh thank you everyone for joining and
looking forward to see you all in the
first session as well as participants so
thank you everyone take care and goodbye